i want to ask you uh prince harry's
writing a book what do you think about
that
with harry i think he's got a lot to say
and i'm really
i'm really i think diana would be really
proud of her of her sons
i just want to know when you decided you
were going to write a romance novel
i decided i was going to write a romance
novel 15 years ago
uh i think i'm fascinated in uh in
research i was doing for young victoria
the film i made if you remember
with emily blunt and rupert friend and
that was based on my books
and so then i produced it with martin
scorsese and graham king
and julian fellows wrote the screenplay
and i was so immersed in the
fabulousness of the history of that
period
that i then decided i was gonna write a
novel and i've always wanted to write
enough
are you a romantic at heart i i mean
kevin i i mean he's my everest high
i am such a romantic i i love
do you know what kevin actually i really
want to take your questions seriously
i deeply believe in the romance
of life of the fact that my dogs are
barking
but but it i i love the fact that maybe
the
storytelling isn't it romance and
storytelling is who they chasing
and uh and what was it a letter that was
being delivered to me with some really
great news you know
or um if i'm aromantic at heart
i have lived every girl's dream of
marrying a prince is there
a little you and lady margaret since you
have lived this
fabulous life and you have been a
princess
in all those things uh
kevin there is no question about it i
like the fact that you've read the book
kevin so that's exciting
but uh sarah margaret i.e me
and of course there's lady margaret who
happens to be redheaded and
i think that when you are red-headed
you're deeply passionate about life
and deeply in in in love with
how intoxicating it can be uh when
you're thrown into the
onto the public stage as a as a princess
it's pretty
you couldn't you can't get better than
that i've always wanted all my life to
be a show jumper actually and jump in
the olympic team for show jumping
okay so i did you know but i was
incredible incredibly unlucky to marry
a wonderful prince and became a princess
so it's pretty great
by the way congratulations because this
is going to be turned into
a tv series tell me about that i'd like
this to be a series because i think lady
margaret can run and run i think there
could be lots of different books
about lady margaret on the other hand i
have just signed a contract
with william mora to do my next book so
two novels in one year is not bad kevin
[Music]
being a parent and now a grandparent how
how do you and andrew
grandparent together uh well
you know it really annoys me because i
spend my life in
my average age of three to five on my
story time with fergie and friends
which i do every day at four o'clock uh
it and it goes global into free into
hospitals and care homes and dating
very popular it is very very popular
thank you thank you and hole in the wall
gang shout out to them
uh but but just just uh i i look at the
way he is with august his grandson
and he's so good with him i have sort of
grandpa envy you know he's really good
with him
and the thing you know this is my three
to five is my
is my genre and yet your really good
grandpa so
we we he's a very good parent she's a
very good co-parent
and he's a very uh deeply kind man and
he has such compassion
are we supposed to move forward from
there this novel gives us bridgeton
vibes were you
was bridgette in the back of your mind
or were you thinking about bridgerton at
all
the good news is bridgeton came out
after i'd finished my novel
ha right i thank you
and so uh i have been uh because i am a
storyteller i have been
uh very much uh wanting to uh tell the
drama it's 24 meets pride and prejudice
really this book and so therefore that's
why it's so
deeply exciting that this character goes
against the confines of 1870 where she
was to be
controlled by men and ladybug does not
wish to be controlled by
men and i think this could be a little
similarity between
the author and her heroine but just
saying
if i'm not to put all my eggs in one
basket i must
collect more eggs
the duke truly has put your head in a
spin i mean
look you're right and the way that she
rebels and she says i'm gonna chart my
own path
is amazing and that's kind of your life
that no matter what you've charted your
own path regardless of what people say
yes now kevin the great thing about that
is that sometimes when you charter your
own path and you follow your compass you
could hit a few storms couldn't you
and the waves are quite high
and so and you don't listen to anyone
and you just go for it and i think
at 61 maybe i have a much better
understanding
of the strength of my own voice now
and that's really pretty exciting and
it's taken me a long time
to get to this voice now looking back
all the storms did they make you tougher
uh when you're stratospherically
sensitive
you take everything personally and you
mind
terribly and living with being so
sensitive
never changes so when the front pages
were really cruel
about me i i took it to heart
and then i believed it and when when
you can keep your head when all men
doubt you i roger kipling wrote if
and and i never understood that they
weren't really having a go at me
bad for you selling papers and i took it
to heart
and then i probably acted out being a
self-saboteur or whatever it might be
i think in the time of the 80s when
diana and i were were out and about
there wasn't social media and so they
really did have a
really good go and you didn't have time
on you couldn't answer back and so you
just
it it doesn't toughen you up um kevin it
actually makes you have more empathy
and and it makes you well in my case
and i remember my grandmother saying
when you feel bad about yourself give to
others
and i remember clearly when uh it was a
really bad
uh morning you know i don't know what
the newspapers had written about me
something like 82 would rather sleep
with a goat than fergie or something
charming like that
and and i went to an als
conference up in birmingham and
in the front row was a man from
australia who was in a wheelchair
and on the stage everyone was you know
i was very upset and the front pages
were awful i mean really bad kevin
and uh he i went to talk to him this man
and he said you know i haven't got out
of my chair for a very long time but i'm
going to stand up for you
i can't walk because i have als but i'm
going to stand for you
because he said i want to prove a point
that we don't mind what they write
we just love you fergie because you're
prepared
to shout and and make awareness
of our diabolical awful disease so do
you think we mind
and i suddenly thought gosh sarah stop
being so self-centered
you know okay so it's very bad and who's
judging but you're your worst judge
you you're you're destroying yourself
when
all these people wanted was me to shout
out about we need to raise money
and research for als never forgotten it
wow that's a powerful story you know you
you mentioned diana and the crown is
you're one of your favorite shows you
reached out to the folks from the crown
and say hey can i help you can i can i
help you with the story lines
what do you think about what do you
think about the crown the
thing is is andy harris is was a friend
or is a good friend of my friend and uh
so i reached out to him actually to talk
to him about uh
making my book into a series in fact
right
yes i thought good he's done so well
with the crown he can do
my my series for me on on her heart for
campus
right that's how i actually reached out
to him and then while i was
while i was on to him i said um talking
about that if you want any help with
with uh with the true story of my
character do let me know
because i sometimes think that if the
person's really alive
right now and they're going to portray
me as something else i quite like to get
the story right
and you like that one because it's the
most expensive
no because it reminds me of my mother's
engagement ring
and it's the same color as my eyes are
they getting it right in the crown
do they get it right well i i don't
think i'm in it so that's fine um
i'm not in it so that's okay but i'm not
like that kevin i
it doesn't have to be about me i'm i'm
i'm
in fact rachel kohan at william morrow
in the first run of the
novel she came back to me and said i'd
like to see my friend
more and her strong voice and less of
self-deprecating
sarah i want to see the strong person i
know her to be
and she was dead right and i think the
pandemic and
covid has has taught me uh and given me
a real
real tap on the shoulder and said get on
it get on it you know
you haven't got time and that it's time
now to go forward with a strong voice
i want to ask you uh prince harry's
writing a book what do you think about
that
his his book that is coming up well
i think the fact that that megan's
written a children's book is really good
well done her because anyone that can
sits there with writing a book it's
really hard i don't know kevin whether
you've written any books
but it's i mean i've written 70 and and
i'm
loving my my writing but it's hard
because you have to keep it all in very
condensed if it's children's
um with with with harry i think he's got
a lot to say and
i think diana would be really proud of
her of her sons
and and their wives and the grandsons
and
and uh you know he's such a good boy you
know
i think in life you that there's no
question
that there's far too far too much
judgment
and it should be more compassion and
support in every way
on everybody i my mission statement of
my charity is
you know race creed color or any other
denomination we stand together and we
fight for the right for a child to dare
to dream
well you know i think oh diana would be
so proud of her sons
and and i oh by the way it's quite funny
i was thinking
that if donna was here we'd be
she'd win the three-legged and the egg
and spoon race with the grandchildren
because she always ran faster than me uh
but i might be to the bouncy castle but
the grandchildren wouldn't get her
looking
[Music]
do you know this thursday marks the 40th
anniversary since
charles and diana's wedding what do you
remember about that day
oh that's so sweet kevin no one's asked
me that
um diana gave me the material
to wear and turquoise and
it was beautiful she loved me wearing
turquoise
and that's really good you asked me that
because no one's asking that question
and she was my best friend since she was
14 and i was
16 and she put me on
dome a row a at simples
for her wedding and it was the greatest
greatest i couldn't have a better seat
and i was very proud that she'd given me
the material to wear it already
oh that was a beautiful dress it's just
that day was so iconic and it feels like
the entire world stopped to watch that
moment
and also um kevin hold on a minute july
23rd 86 was the entire the entire
country got a holiday that day to watch
me
get married in a fast coach in a glass
coach
can you believe me and white horses
and and glass coats and white horses and
i was the last
person to go to their wedding in the
glass coach
wow i know so you are talking to
cinderella
cinderella you still you still live with
your prince charming in a way so how
does that how is that working is that is
that you know you guys seem to do it
in a perfect way well you're very kind
we are very happily divorced to each
other it seems to work
i i suppose he uh
understands that i have um i have a lot
to do in the world i'm a philanthropist
i bet you've never heard that word
before a philanthropy from the heart
and uh and i my job my children have
donated
me to the world's children and now and
now they've donated grandma to the
world's children too
it's just where i'm happiest to be to
fly free um
to do to build my schools in sierra
leone
liberia ukraine poland all over the
place
and i i guess that's why i started as a
red
budget helicopter i i just fly free i am
i am
i i am very lucky to get on very well
but we do
practice the three c's which is
communicate compromise
compassion it's a beautiful thing to see
really it is